Talk about constructivism and I'm going
to primarily discuss John Piaget,
although the readings extend to stumped
some degree out past his thought.
Um,
PSA is generally regarded as a
developmental psychologist,
which is not what he thought of himself.
He thought that he was at genetic
epistemologist,
which is a term that I think has ever
only been applied to him.
An epistemologist is someone who studies
the manner in which knowledge,
um,
who studies knowledge itself.
And that's what Piaget thought that he
was doing.
And he wanted to understand how it was
that knowledge unfolded across time.
And more importantly than that,
he wanted to understand how the
cognitive structures that made up in the
individual developed across time.
So that's generally why he's regarded as
a developmental psychologist because of
course he also studied children.
Now
I'm going to read you something that
piaget rope to begin this.
Um,
he wrote an awful lot of books and a lot
of them haven't yet been translated and
some of the ones that are translated are
translated pretty badly.
And I think this is probably an example
of a fairly bad translation,
but regardless of that,
the point that's being made is both
valid and interesting.
So the Garmin postulate a various
traditional epistemologies,
which are theories of valid knowledge is
that knowledge is a fact say or a set of
facts so that you would go to class and
learn a set of facts and that is what
would give you knowledge instead of a
process.
And if our various forms of noman
drawings incomplete as we know they are,
because they're replaced sequentially,
I mean,
for example,
recently in the domain of physics,
physicists revealed to us that they
really didn't understand what some
massive percentage of the universe was
made up.
I think,
I can't remember,
it's 75% or 95% made up of dark matters,
which has never been detective.
And we know how to think about it.
So that's a good example of how our
fundamental assumptions can be
challenged at any moment.
And how a fact can turn from a fact into
a clear fallacy if our various forms of
knowledge,
you're always in complete.
And our various sciences still imperfect
that which is acquired is acquired and
can therefore be studied statically.
So the proposition there is that you
come and you learn the facts and the
facts themselves are solid bits of
information and they don't change across
time.
And so that once you have them,
you have them.
Now of course piaget,
obviously delts that hence the absolute
position of the problems.
What is knowledge or how were the
various types of knowledge possible as
an alternative under the converging
influence of a series of factors,
we're tending more and more today to
regard knowledge as a process more than
a state,
any being or object that science is
attempt to hold fast dissolves.
Once again in the current of
development,
it is the last analysis of this
development and the vid alone that we
have the right to state.
It is a fact.
What it means by that is the fact that
human beings learn facts is in fact a
fact,
right?
So you are capable of learning things
and he thinks that's sort of the
fundamental fact.
People assimilate information and they
transformed as a consequence of it.
And so studying that as he says what we
can and should then seek is a law of
this process.
We are well aware on the other hand that
the fine book by Kuhn Scientific
Revolutions.
Now the reason PSA throws them in at the
end.
How many of you know about Thomas Kuhn's
book on scientific resolutions?
No one just to three people.
Okay,
well that's probably not good.
Um,
Kuhn was one of the 20th century's
foremost philosophers of science and he
made a distinction between two different
modes of scientific process.
One,
he called normal science and the other
he called Revolutionary Science.
And normal science was the kind of
science then you'll do as undergraduates
unless you're incredibly lucky or
unbelievably brilliant.
Um,
or probably unbelievably really an Andy,
incredibly lucky.
And so normal science occurs when you
generate knowledge incrementally from
within the confines of an already
developed scientific theory.
So a normal science would be a say the
application of big five models of
personality to the prediction of some
other variable like say relationship
success.
You're going to uncover something new,
but it's not going to shake the
foundations of knowledge itself.
Now,
coon observed that from time to time
there were discoveries that were made
that shook the foundation of knowledge
itself.
There's some well known revolutions in
science,
so the Newtonian Revolution was a
revolution in science.
Uh,
Einstein's were produced another
revolution in science.
Darwin's were Mendel's work.
Um,
those are the revolutionary
transformations of thought that people
often considered.
Did I say Darwin?
I certainly should have said Darwin
because his was probably the most
revolutionary of all.
Um,
now the reason that I wanted to tell you
that,
and the reason I kept it in here,
even though it seems like it's funny,
little additional statement pin to the
end of Piaget's Caucasian,
is that cool,
observed at scientists science seem to
progress in accordance with the same
mechanisms that Piaget observed,
that the knowledge of children appeared
to progress.
Now,
one of the things that you'll learn
about piaget,
which is generally all you learned if
you learned about piaget,
is his idea that children go through
sequential stages of development and
usually people have you memorize those
stages.
I should let you know that piaget really
didn't care that much about those
stages.
And when they occurred and how they
could be sped up at what they were.
He was much more interested in deep
philosophical questions.
And that element of his work generally
goes unrecognized by the North American
psychologist who purport to understand
what he had to say now because he wrote
dozens of books,
some of which are not yet translated.
It's not surprising that people come
away with a partial view of key Jay when
you're that prolific.
He was so damn smart.
He was offered the curatorship of a
museum when he was 10 because he had
published a scientific paper on,
I think it was on snails and but his
parents requested that he turned it
down.
So you know,
piaget was a major genius and if someone
puts their mind like that puts their
mind to work for an entire lifetime and
he lived to be an old match,
they can produce an awful lot of
intellectual material and it's not
necessary,
especially if it can't be summarized
easily as a single,
you know,
coherence theory that you could memorize
in one page.
It's pretty hard for people to keep up.
So it's not surprising that his thought
gets reduced to,
you know,
a set of axioms is in a sense,
but the devil is often in the detail
with great thinkers.
And what that means is that to really
understand what they had to say,
you actually have to read them because a
lot of the information is at the
sentence level of analysis and not at
the summary Level of analysis.
You know,
if you're really smart,
it's not that easy to summarize what you
have to say because most of what you
have to say is in fact informative.
So you can't just throw it away.
It's hard to compress it.
So anyways,
this initial paragraph opens up the
world of Constructivism to now the
constructivists are interesting people
because you know,
you'll often hear people ask is it
genetic or environmental,
which is,
it's not a good question because it's a
false dichotomy that the genes formulate
structures in accordance with
environmental demand right from the
beginning of the organisms emergence.
And so there's a constant interplay
between the environment and genetics.
But the environment isn't also just a
thing that's out there that's like made
out of lions and Tigers of Moose and
buildings and you know,
the sky.
It's,
it's an information field and the
constructivist point outrightly that
partly what you're doing when you're
operating in the world is interacting
with this field of information and
incorporating it structure into the
structure of your mind and body,
which is how you adapt.
So you could say in some sense that
you're built out of information and
matter.
That's a good way of thinking about it
and the constructivists or very
interesting interested in how you go
about acquiring information and how you
then transform that information into the
sort of knows that you can apply to the
world.
So they're also very pragmatic,
especially piaget because Piaget regards
knowledge as um,
like the prerequisite for adaptive
action.
So again,
again,
he's less concerned about the facts that
you know about the structure of the
world that he is about.
How is that you modify and adapt your
behavior so that you could survive in
the world.
So,
so that's the first pos,
that's constructivism.
And then the next postulate is that
there are revolutions in this internal
structures that you construct that
emerge as a consequence of you acquiring
new information.
Sometimes that information can already
be fit into a knowledge structure that
you possess,
but sometimes the information is so
anomalous or novel that it blows out
fundamental precept positions that
you've already established and forces
you to not only add some information to
your repertoire of information,
but to reconfigure the structure you use
to represent the information you don't
like that people don't like it when that
happens,
it's too dramatic and upsetting.
So which is often why revolutions in
science or in an APP,
any other field,
our first resistance,
I mean it's very complicated.
The reasons people are opposed to new
ideas are very complicated.
There's lots of theories about why that
occurs.
Precisely.
But I'll briefly outline and good
theory.
There's a bunch of them,
but a log line one.
So let's say there's already a
scientific theory and it's instantiated
in the world.
So people accept it.
And let's say that you are a proponent
of that theory.
So you might say,
well,
that theory therefore governs your
worldview.
And if I threaten it,
then your world view is going to fall
apart and that's going to make you fall
apart.
And that's not a bad theory,
but here's a,
here's a variant of that which is
similar,
but which I think is better.
So I'm a professor,
let's say I have a theory now what I'm
doing with my theory is buying my right
to be a professor.
So I would come to the University of
Toronto as a job candidate and I would
say,
here's my theory and here's why I think
the facts support it.
Here's what it's good for.
And they'll say,
okay,
it looks like you know enough about what
you're doing so that you can occupy this
position in this dominance hierarchy.
Okay.
And I'm pretty happy about that because
that position in that dominance
hierarchy is pretty permanent.
That's one of the advantages to an
academic job.
It's like once you have it,
as long as you're relatively confident
and relatively ethical,
then you can,
you can maintain it across time.
So,
so it's a big deal to be granted that
slot.
And then being in that dominance
hierarchy is not only a matter of what
you believe,
obviously the fact that I'm in the
donuts,
he means I get a certain salary and
that's not hypothetical that allows me
to eat.
So I'm happy about that.
It's not only psychological and I can
pay my housing payments with it and so
on.
So it protects me from the cold and the
offers me something to eat and it gives
me a certain public status.
And so if some others,
joker comes along,
say they're young and they say,
well,
I have a different theory and it makes
your theory looks stupid,
then I'm not going to be very happy
about that.
Partly because it upsets the way that I
could figure my understanding of the
world.
And that's a drag.
But I might recover from that.
But it also undermines my,
undermines the validity of my claim to
that position in the hierarchy.
And so it sorta makes me an imposter,
say it and say the guy turns out to be
right.
It's like,
poof,
I'm an imposter.
And I knew really no longer really have
the right to occupy that position.
Someone might even point that out,
although it doesn't happen very often.
In the case of professors,
you know what happens fairly frequently
in other sorts of occupations.
You know,
all of a sudden your position has made
useless because somebody figured out how
to automate you and poof you're gone.
Like that's hard on your world view but
it's a lot harder on your celery.
So a lot of the reasons that people
claim to the validity of their theories
is because it gives them a claim to a
certain kind of,
uh,
what would you call,
skillset and utility that then gives
them a claim to occupy a certain
position in the dominance hierarchy and
that protects them from,
from,
you know,
all the horrors of reality.
Not Completely,
but you know,
I mean I have health insurance for
example.
Sometimes that's really,
really helpful.
So I don't want some joker coming along
and pointing out that my theory is,
is right.
Anyway,
so far that hasn't happened.
So that's a good thing as far as I'm
concerned.
So psg concludes and says,
if all knowledge is always in a state of
development and consists in proceeding
from one state to a more complete and
efficient one,
evidently it is a question of knowing
this development and analyzing it with
the greatest possible accuracy.
Okay.
So Piaget fingers,
you're a information foraging machine so
to speak,
and the process that you engage in while
you're forging from information for
information and then figuring out what
to do with it is typical to human
beings.
And there's some constancy of structure
across human beings.
Okay.
So that's,
that's the first idea.
It isn't that we all do it in a
different way,
even though there's individual
variation,
obviously.
Um,
the other sort of fundamental postulate
of constructivism,
especially the Phn Ian version of
Constructivism,
is that you sort of build yourself from
the bottom up,
starting with your body.
So Pia,
this is one of the things about Piaget's
theory that's unbelievably
sophisticated,
I think.
So when people were first developing
models of artificial intelligence,
they thought they'd be able to develop
machines,
that sort of model of the world and then
figured out how to act.
In the world sort of abstractly and then
would after they figured out how to act
in the world would then act in the
world.
But that proved to be impossible.
And as you can tell,
because we don't have,
you know,
ambulatory robots that could like bus
tables at a restaurant,
which turns out to be,
by the way a very complex job,
fast mathematical operations.
Computer can handle that easily or
easily,
but bussing a table.
It's like no computer is smart enough to
do that.
So that's pretty peculiar.
But it turned out after like 40 years of
investigation that you couldn't build
computers that would operate as
independent robots by teaching them
tomorrow the world.
And then by having the model,
the potential action that they were
going to undertake and then implementing
it.
That did not work.
Partly because modeling the world is way
more complicated than anybody ever
suspected.
It's like infinitely more complicated.
And so some robotics engineers such as
Rodney Brooks who worked at Mit,
started building robots from the bottom
up.
He made these little mindless robots
that really didn't even have a sense
essential processor that we're action
oriented.
So like the first things he built where
he's literally the sec,
like things that could skitter away from
light,
that's all they could do.
It turn a light,
poof,
they'd go find some dark.
And it's as if,
so imagine the world to that roadblock
was a binary place.
It was either a light place where a dark
place and then you might say,
well what did life or dark mean to this
little robot?
Then you have to ask yourself,
well what does meaning mean?
And that,
that's a very good question.
It's one that piaget answers meaning
means to that the robot
move to a different place.
So light to that robot meant move to a
different place.
So what the,
what the robot in a sense was doing was
transforming one form of information,
light versus dark into another form,
which was skitter away.
And so I love that because it's not easy
to understand what meaning means until
you relate it to the body.
And so piaget's fundamental proposition
is that the,
the elements of your understanding are
not perceptual abstractions.
In fact,
there's even elements of understanding
that underlie your perceptual
abstractions that are more fundamental
and what those are essentially our
sensory motor skills.
Things you do with your body.
It's a lovely idea.
It's extremely profound and I think it's
absolutely correct.
It,
it does wreak havoc with the idea of
disembodied intelligence.
However,
because for Piaget and also for Rodney
Brooks who is responsible by the way,
just so you know,
some of you've seen big dog,
big dog look up Darpa,
Da Rpa.
How many of you have seen big dog?
How many of you are terrified by big
dog?
Yes.
Big Dog is this robot that's being
developed by the U s army that it's
about this big and it's four legged.
It's got ahead and it could run like
faster than you and it can run in snow
and it can run on ice and it can run up
hills.
And if you kick it,
if balances and stands back oxen
hypothetically it's going to be used to
transport like the heavy things that
soldiers have to carry.
But you know,
don't believe that that's a stupid idea.
Once these things can emulate by
themselves and they can already follow
each other because now they have visual
systems,
um,
arming that is going to be a very simple
matter.
And so the probability that we'll have
unbelievably super fast robots that can
shoot you in 10 years is like,
to me as far as I can tell from the
development is absolutely certain.
I have a friend who's a computer
engineer and he's a really good,
and he said,
you know how in science fiction movies
sometimes when those robot shooting at
you,
they miss.
You said when the robots shoot it,
you not only will they shoot at where
you are,
but they'll shoot it.
The six places that they calculate your
most likely to dark too and they will
never miss.
So that's a lovely thing to think about.
So
hopefully that will come to pass,
but it probably will.
So here's the sort of thing that PSA was
interested in.
These are very fundamental questions and
he was a very deep intellect.
So he tried to go right to the bottom of
the structures of knowledge to find out
what was down there
upon what does an individual basis
judgments.
That's a good one.
How do you know where they do a or b or
what the differences between right and
wrong.
How has that instantiated in your,
in your being,
what are your norms?
How is it that those norms are
validated?
What's the interest of such norms for
the philosophy of science in general,
which,
which is a question like,
well,
there's a consensual reality that we all
share to some degree,
which is why we can communicate,
but there's not a one to one
relationship between that consensual
reality and the categories of science.
So Piaget was interested in the
similarities between our consensual
viewpoint and the scientific viewpoint.
And the differences.
So for example,
people use to hypothetically assume that
the world was flat.
Um,
and you could say,
well,
the reason they assumed that was because
it looks flat when you look at it.
So it was an empirical observation,
but obviously there were other
observations that we managed to produce.
It indicated that the world wasn't flat
and then our scientific conceptions and
our interpersonal,
uh,
consensual norms
became divorced from one another.
And that's becoming a really serious
problem,
say with branches of science,
like quantum mechanics,
which you know,
there are absolutely completely
incomprehensible from a pragmatic
perspective,
even to those who formulate the
mathematically I pay a piaget would say
the reason for that is that,
well,
when we interact with objects at the
phenomenal,
phenomenal logical level,
which is the level that we can most
easily perceive,
they act Newtonian,
you know,
so can I take your pen?
So you know,
you can sort of predict what this
penalty,
because it acts like other objects of
about its size and shape with mass.
And so your understanding of this is
actually based upon your knowledge of
what will happen if you manipulate this
thing with your body.
You know it's solid.
You'd be very surprised if you could
like put your fingers through this pen.
You'd be surprised if it broke because
you expect a certain hardness.
You do expect it to write,
although pins off to dote,
you expect it to be pointy.
You know that you can take it apart into
many objects.
Even though like you can ask how many
objects is this?
Well,
it's one pen,
right?
But you could take it apart.
Now it's two objects.
And then you can see that there's other
objects in here and sometimes you can
put it back together and it'll still
work.
And so,
so Psj,
his point is that what we regard as
understanding to say that you understand
something is to indicate that you can
predict what is going to occur if you
interact with that object with your
bottom.
Okay.
And that's,
that gives you your intuitive
understanding of things.
And so because this is material other,
you already know something about other
things that are material right and you
can transfer it from place to place.
And that's again an embodied knowledge
because material things are those things
through which you cannot put your hand
right.
You'd get some weird things like smoker
clouds and it's like,
well are they,
what are they?
Are they objects?
Is a cloud and object?
Well No,
not really.
Cause an object is one of these things
that you could sort of manipulate as a
unit.
Now the categories of quantum mechanics,
of course,
which deal with these incredibly tiny
things that are really don't want
particles and are really not waves,
they're in comprehensible to us because
we never manipulate anything at that
scale.
And so because we can't play with it,
we have no real way of understanding it
because our understanding is based on
the mapping of objects onto our body.
So any object that we can map onto her
body is therefore fundamentally and
comprehensible.
It's very cool theory,
you know,
and it very body centric theory.
So how does the fact that children think
differently than we do affect our
presumption?
In fact itself?
That's a very interesting question too
is like,
so you've got three year olds and of
course they're pretty clueless about the
world but,
and,
and you know more,
but there's the three year old is alive
and everything and functioning.
And so then you have to ask yourself,
well,
if their conception of the world is
qualitatively different than your
conception,
how is it that you can both survive in
the same world?
And what does that mean about,
about what knowledge means and about the
limits of knowledge.
I mean not,
you know,
I could say the same thing above you
that you might say about a three year
old,
which is,
well if I took you from this place and
dropped you in the jungle,
you know,
soon you'd be dead,
first few be visible,
then you'd be dead.
And so that's sort of like the three
year olds state of being.
If you,
you know,
if you were supposed to take care of
them and you disappeared.
So obviously even your knowledge of the
world is limited by wall.
It's limited in its necessary generality
by the context.
But that also has something interesting
to say about the validity of your
knowledge itself.
Very context dependent.
So,
okay,
so that's the sort of thing that piaget
was interested in.
Here's some other ones.
What do you mean by number?
That's an interesting one.
So you don't have,
they say you can't compare apples and
oranges,
but you can.
So if I said,
well what's two oranges plus two apples
for fruits?
Who just said that you sound very good.
So the way you solve that was by
generalizing,
I'm a level,
right?
So if I sat down,
um,
what's two desks plus two rocks,
what would you say?
Yes ma'am.
You're very good at this.
Pretty thing it was done.
That's an Iq.
That's,
those are their Iq questions by the way.
So if you did get them now you could
feel disappointed,
depressed.
If you've got the wild,
then you can pat yourself on the map.
So that's good.
Yeah.
So number is a funny thing because well,
as I pointed out with the Pan,
well one can become many very rapidly
and many can become one.
One of the whole idea of announcer is
extremely difficult to understand.
You know like what is in common between
singular entities that allows you to
represent all of them with one well
animals don't do that.
They can in a sense they can sort of
intuit three or four,
which is about all we can intuit to.
But once we get the nomenclature done
property man,
we can use numbers like crazy and then
they bill us to manipulate reality like
mad.
So whatever it is we're extracting from
the commonality between objects seems to
be something that gives us incredible
power.
So that's a problem.
What do you mean by space?
Since we know for example,
from Einstein's work that you know,
space spaces is not an absolute in any
sense.
It isn't the speeds we move.
So what do you mean by time and speed?
What is an object permanent and when it
isn't it,
and when do you learn that?
What does it mean that an object is the
same across time?
That's a good one.
So,
you know,
I don't know if there's a single
molecule in your body that was there
five months ago,
six months ago.
There's some,
I don't remember what the turnover
duration is,
but it's fairly,
it's fairly quick.
So it's weird day because there you are
and you were there two years ago,
but none of your constituent elements
are the same.
So how is it that you can be the same
now that physicist Schrodinger
Schrodinger of the Schrodinger's cat
fade solved that by claiming that you
were at dissipative structure.
It's very interesting way.
That's when you thought life was
dissipative structures.
Uh,
dissipate.
Dissipative structure is the same as a,
you know,
when you,
when you pull up the,
the,
uh,
he pulled out at the bottom of the sink
stopper,
I think.
So stopper,
if you're a saint is full of water and
you pull up the stopper,
you know,
you get a whirlpool,
right?
And all the water's spins as it as it
goes down the drain hole.
And you'll notice that that whirlpool
look sort of the same across time,
even though obviously the water
molecules that make it up are different.
He called that a dissipated structure.
It was a pattern that maintained itself
in spite of the movement of matter
through it.
And that's what you are,
by the way.
So it requires energy to keep a
dissipative structure intact.
But,
uh,
you take in energy.
So thanks to the sun.
What do you mean by chance?
Huh?
Why do you have moral concerns and what
does it mean that you have moral
concerns?
That you have ideas about how people
should behave and how they shouldn't
behave.
And you have a very deep understanding
of that.
And it's characteristic of all human
beings and many,
many animals.
So where does that come from?
Is it developed form of knowledge?
What are children doing when they're
playing?
What are people doing when they're
dreaming?
And,
uh,
what's the significance of the fact that
you can imitate other people?
Now I'll,
I'll start with the last one briefly.
Um,
you know,
you might think that one of the things
that really distinguishes us from other
creatures animals is the fact that we
have a thumb.
And that's a big one.
We've got very good functional thumbs
and Hooray for that.
And we stand up on two feet.
So we get a chance to use our thumbs and
has to carry things round as a great
things and to take them apart and to
swing sticks and so on.
But there are other animals who can do
that to a limited degree.
And then there's our ability to talk.
That's a major one.
But one of the other things that really
differentiates people from other animals
is,
you know,
you hear monkey see monkey do,
right?
Well that's wrong,
monkey.
See that's the end of that
really can't imitate one another.
And they certainly can't imitate any
even randomly generated normal behavior
that another monkey producers think
about it this way.
You know,
we hear these claims that chimpanzees
have culture.
It's like,
well,
no,
they don't.
Not really.
And the reason for that,
it's easy to figure out that they don't
have culture.
I mean,
let's say chimps have been around
roughly speaking for 50 million years,
which is not a bad estimate because we
diverged from them about 7 million years
ago.
And the evidence is pretty clear that
the thing that we diverged from looked a
lot more like a chimp then it looked
like us.
So like we've been booting it ahead,
madly developing like mad and the chimps
would be laying back and eating leaves,
you know,
so.
So do they have a culture?
Well,
hey that 50 million years,
you know,
they haven't even built a hot yet.
And the reason I'm telling you that is
because if you're a culture generated
creature and you only magine match,
you'll only manage saying one discovery
of a hundred years between all of you.
If you have 50 million years to get your
act together,
that's a lot of hundred year segments.
And so even if the chimpanzee was
building culture at the rate of 0.0,
zero,
zero 1% a year,
if you calm,
calm,
that over 50 million years,
you have the empire state building and
there are the empire state buildings
that chimpanzees are living in.
And so therefore they don't have
culture.
Now they might be able to recognize the,
their peers in the dominance hierarchy.
They can do that and they can use,
maybe they can use simple tools,
but the tools they use seem to be
dependent on the environment that they
inhabit.
You know,
cause some people say,
well some chips use one tool on some
chimps.
Use another button.
You know,
if you're going to live in a rocky
place,
then he might use rocks.
And if you're going to live in a place
that has sticks,
you might use sticks.
But that's not because you're a
different,
it's because the environment's
different.
So anyways,
chimps,
candy,
imitate one another very much.
Um,
but humans,
man were ridiculous.
Like we're,
we're so imitative.
It's absolutely crazy.
You know?
And that's so cool because what it means
is that once you get a pattern of
behavior,
you,
you know,
you whip up a new pattern of behavior,
I can watch you and I can just
instantiate it in my own bloody,
you know,
maybe a bit awkwardly to begin with.
Although maybe sometimes better than you
can.
And Bang,
I've got that.
And so we're always looking around at
each other,
seeing what we're up to.
And as soon as we see someone who's up
to something interesting,
then we can do the same thing.
Children do that cause they imitate,
right?
But there are even better at it.
They generalize across instances of
imitation.
So for example,
you remember when you're a kid and
you're playing,
maybe you're playing house and you're
the mom,
or maybe,
I don't know,
maybe you're the house cat because
children will certainly do that.
And so let's say the child is being the
house cat.
So he or she is down on,
you know,
all forest zoom room,
like a cat maybe meowing and rubbing up
against there mother's leg and looking
for a male milk.
And the below.
They're not exactly imitating their cat
because if they were exactly imitating
their cat,
they would be moving exactly the same
way the cat move.
But now they're not.
What they're doing is they've observed
the cat across a wide variety of in of
environments.
They abstracted what constitutes
generalized cat behavior from all of
those instances.
And then they can instantiate the spirit
of the cap,
which is sort of the movements that make
up cactus.
And then you,
because you're so smart,
you can watch them zooming around on the
ground and despite the fact that they
don't have a tail or ears or refer,
you're going to figure it out pretty
quick.
That that is now a cat.
And children do the same thing with
their parents.
Like if they're playing house and the
imitate their father,
you know,
they may to some degree to try to
imitate the sound of his voice and maybe
even use a couple of his favorite
phrases.
But basically what they're doing is
trying to act like a father rather than
imitating their father.
So it's like imminence,
Metta,
imitation,
right?
It's like,
watch you,
I watch you,
I watch you.
There's commonalities across all of
those instances.
I extract the commonalities,
I embody it.
And then when I played that's what I'm
doing.
I'm figuring out how to embody the
commonalities across multiple exposures.
And that's,
that's you're doing that when you're
like three,
you're so smart.
And then even if you're asleep you're
doing it because you're doing it and
your dreams and so human beings do that.
No other animals do.
So when you're thinking about the ways
that we're weird,
you want to put invitation way up there
on the list because you can,
you know,
think about death.
People like congenitally deaf people
don't have much access to language.
You know say they don't learn sign
language because that used to happen in
the past.
It's like they can still wander around
in the world and in well why?
Well because they're so good at
imitating,
you know they get all the non verbal
stuff and that's a lot.
So languages,
you know,
great to all that APP which actually
enables you to imitate across space and
time.
That's what it's for.
Because,
you know,
maybe you whip up a new action and then
you write it down in words and then you
sent it to someone and they,
those are instructions by the way,
cause that's what instructions are you
send out to someone and then they read
your code for behavior and then they act
it out.
And so language enables you to move
invitation across space and time.
And that's a really good way of
conceptualizing and language because
it's a phd anyway because sometimes we
might think that language is there to
describe the world.
You know,
in the scientific sense,
George Kelly kind of thinks that,
that thought that,
that human beings are sort of like
natural scientists,
but natural scientists are much more
concerned with what is then with how to
act.
So Kelly's wrong.
What human beings are more like it's
natural engineers because we're always
zooming around and trying to figure out
how to fiddle with things much more than
what they are.
And as I mentioned to you earlier,
a pragmatist would say,
well it's an artificial distinction
because things are
what they are when you fiddle with them.
That's in fact what they are.
So it's,
that's pretty smart.
He goes,
he also says this is part of the
constructivist notion cause
constructivism is a philosophical
school.
He says no does nothing to get in the
eye and it does not begin in the object.
It begins in the interactions.
There's a reciprocal and simultaneous
construction of the subject on the one
hand and the object on the other.
There is no structure apart from
construction,
either abstract or genetic.
I really liked that.
I showed you some of the symbolic
categories and a couple of you know,
previous lectures and I mentioned for
example that one of the symbolic
categories is the great father and a
great father kind of stamps for cultural
structure.
Whereas the great mother stands for
novelty and and then and,
and sometimes the terrifying.
Anyways,
back to the great father.
There's a precondition in constructivism
that there has to be three things that
exist.
They map right onto that symbolic
structure.
One is culture.
So when you look at something or really
with any creature looks at something,
there's an inbuilt structure that
characterizes the creatures,
some of which would be biological built
in,
there's some of which would be acquired
that they must have in order to
structure their perceptions of what
they're looking at.
So you don't come to the situation
blank.
You know,
for example,
you have two eyes so you can have stereo
vision.
Most of the time,
you know when you have five senses in
there at the same census and there's
more than that.
You have snake detection circuits for
example.
So you're sort of primed to respond to a
certain class of predators.
You like sweet tastes and sour taste,
but you don't really like spinner
tastes.
So on and so forth.
Like right from the beginning,
you've written how landscape of
interpreter structures in order to
frame and simplify
the world that you are exposed to.
Now the world itself is this sort of
amorphous thing.
It's amorphous cause it's so
multidimensional and complex.
There's so much of it.
It's like a fog that contains
everything.
And so unless you can frame that and
simplify it and narrow it,
it's very difficult for you to
understand and interact with it at all.
I mean,
you,
you know,
you just can't deal with everything at
once.
It's hard enough to deal with one little
thing at a time.
And you know,
this internal structure is partly what
enables you to deal with one little
thing at a time.
And then so there's you and there's the,
the source of all information.
There's the structure of you and the
source of all information.
And then,
then there's the process that's you in
the process that's you,
is you using your appendages
fundamentally and your census to
interact with things and to make the
manifest new properties.
Right?
And so those are properties that they
might not manifest without you there.
And it's very difficult for you to tell
when you're interacting with the world,
even at a perceptual level,
how much of what you observe wouldn't be
there if you weren't there.
No.
So because one of the big philosophical
questions is,
well,
what's there?
And when you're not there.
And that is a much more complicated
question than you might imagine.
Um,
the,
the Dallas would say,
well,
what's,
there is so much an amalgam of
everything at once that it might as well
be nothing at all.
And it's sort of a,
I can give you a way of understanding
that.
So let's say you took every symphony
that was ever written,
recorded,
hey,
and then you took all those recordings
together and you laid one on top of the
other and you'd say,
well no,
I've got like every symphony at once on
a tape.
And then you played the tape.
What would it sound like?
It sound like white noise.
So it sounds like,
so you could say white noise is
functionally equivalent to every single
symphony that's ever been written.
Every piece of music that's ever been
written,
all being played at once.
So what,
you know,
so when the Dallas would also say,
you have to remember that what something
is,
is just as dependent on what it isn't as
it is dependent on what it is.
So that's a tough one,
but it's very,
very smart.
So the constructor,
this would certainly agree with that.
No.
Bruner who was a constructivist of
sorts,
put a little twist on Piaget's idea,
which I'm going to borrow because I
think it makes explaining piaget easier.
At least it makes it easier for me.
And since I'm explaining it,
that's that's what we're going to have
to go for it.
Bruner said,
we seem to have no other way of
describing live time.
Save in a form of narrative.
Now the reason I think this is a Ph in
constructivist claim is because piaget
is concerned with knowledge as it
emerges from action.
And action is clearly represented
narratives,
right?
Because the narrative is about what the
characters are doing.
So narrative is the way that we
represent the information about doing so
and knowledge for Piaget is about doing.
So I just put the two together and that
and that.
There's other reasons for it too.
And that makes it simpler to explain.
So here's,
here's a way of thinking about how we
put a structure on the world.
So I'm not mentioned,
I kind of introduced you to this idea
before.
So you're headed somewhere wherever that
happens to be because you're an active
organism and so you're,
you know,
even if you're don't have any immediate
needs,
you're going to poke about things just
because you're curious.
It turns out that your dopaminergic
system,
which is the system that drives
curiosity,
fires at a certain constant rate,
even if you're not hungry or tired or
thirsty or you know,
even if no primary needs are clamoring
for your attention.
So your,
your default comfortable status,
mildly curious about everything.
And so that's part of what makes you an
information for a jury.
Because when you have nothing better to
do so to speak,
you'll just poke around and see what
happens because you never know that no
itch might come in useful in the future.
So anyways,
you're always going from point a to
point b because you're active and in the
way you get from point a to point B,
even if point b is an abstraction
because it often is,
you know,
I am going towards a better future.
Well that's kind of a weird abstraction.
How are you going to get there?
Well,
you can be sure that at the base it's
going to involve movement,
right?
Because you get to that future,
there's,
there's movements you're going to have
to bake.
So
see
structured this
going to go ahead to something
sick.
Okay.
So we're going to look at this.
We're do look at this diagram,
then we're gonna go back.
So,
um,
let's start with an abstract
philosophical concepts.
I want to be a good person.
While you might debate forever about
what the good beans,
right?
It's the sort of philosophical conundrum
that you can fall into because you take
an abstractions and then you might think
of it as a property if the world,
and it's something that's subject to put
in the bait,
which is exactly what's happening in the
history of mankind.
But there's another way of looking at it
that's actually probably more accurate.
And I would say almost more useful.
And this is the way,
so you're going to try to be a good
person.
Well,
the Phn and view,
it would be being a good person.
It's not a state of mind.
What it is,
is it abstraction that represents all
first other associated abstractions.
Because we could say,
well,
being a good person,
it's a multidimensional problems,
right?
You can't,
you can't just be good and then it's
done.
It's like being a good person might be
being good at.
Well what?
Well good at being a friend.
Good at being a lover,
good at being a parent,
good at being a child,
good at being an employee.
You can know,
you could say what good is,
what's the same across all those things.
And PSJ would call that a scheme just so
you know,
because the scheme is what's the same
across multiple different things.
So,
and the scheme is the basis of
abstraction for Psa.
So good person is the sum total or the
or the commonalities between being a
good
teacher,
student,
employee,
etc. Okay.
So then we'll say,
okay,
so now we can move the problem with
analysis one level down and we can say,
okay,
well what does it mean to be a good
parent?
And then you'd say,
well,
maybe you have to have a good job
because you know,
otherwise you and your child starved.
But we'll forget about that one for a
moment.
And then you might say,
well,
you have to do a good job of taking care
of your family.
Okay,
so you notice we're zeroing in on an
element of the good here and it's still
an abstraction care for your family.
That's an extraction.
So then they might say,
well one of the things you would do if
you care through your family is playing
with the baby.
And another might be complete a meal.
So we'll take the play with the baby
example,
and then there's three things you can do
with your baby peek at it.
They liked that.
So optic permanent.
Say there's nothing more thrilling to a
baby.
Then discovering that you're still there
when you disappear like a baby,
you can amuse her baby for hours with
that discovery because it's by no means
self evident to the baby.
That's a Piagetian notion.
They lack off object permanence.
So as far as they're concerned,
it's a hell of a shock when you
disappear because they were just
appreciate it and you'd be there and
then they're just a shark when you
reappear and you can,
it's so interesting to watch them
because when a baby gets startled,
like when you get started with,
you know,
you might go like that if you're really
starting a baby,
it's like it's whole body is starting,
right?
Like it makes a weird face and it moves
its arms and its legs and then it takes
me like five seconds to recover.
You know,
they really have a startle reflex,
so,
and they'll often laugh.
I'm sure you've seen the laughing babies
on youtube because of course there's
like a 2 billion views of laughing
babies,
which is a good thing.
It shows that we like babies.
I think there's one that's very famous
where a baby is reacting to his mother
either sneezing or coughing
caught.
It's absolutely hilarious.
This baby just has a fit.
And what's basically happening is it's
mother costs,
I think it's coughs or sneezes.
He knows.
Oh,
okay.
Oh yeah.
She blows her nose.
So she makes this weird elephant like
noise and the baby's mother could do
this and then get surprised at its own
startle.
And that makes it,
that's a really interesting phenomena
from a Piagetian perspective because one
of the things that Piaget noticed the
children did because they could imitate,
was imitate themselves.
That's how they got to know who they
were.
So for example,
if a child would say chub would actually
up north that off,
but the reading,
well that's a hell of a thing to
discover.
You know,
if you move your arm just a little bit,
that will fall off.
That's cool.
So then maybe you can do that 60 70
times while you're supposed to be
eating.
And the other thing that's really cool
about doing that as that mom,
Lou immediately rushed over and picked
it up and put it back.
And this is an excellent game.
You can entertain yourself with that for
like a month.
And basically what you're discovering is
the relationship between your movements
and gravity,
right?
It's like this is a major leak
discovery.
It's no wonder you're obsessed with it.
So.
So anyways,
the point with regards to the invitation
is maybe the baby does this accidentally
to begin with.
That startles them and then it's put up
again and then they think,
well that was cool.
Wonder if we can do that again.
And then they're pretty happy with that.
And then they'll keep practicing that
until they get like expert at doing
that.
So instead of using like gross body
movements to do it,
which is how they'd start,
they get developed finer and finer and
finer body movements until they've got
the whole narky light thing off a table
down.
And it can even be fascinating as an
adult.
Some of them,
you've probably played table hockey,
you know with the quarter,
you know how to do that.
Put a quarter on a table.
It's not very complicated.
You make little goals.
Your,
your job is to flip the thing so that it
just sits that far over the table and so
that the appointment can flip it up.
That's,
that's like your opportunity to score a
goal.
My point is playing with how things move
in relationship to friction and gravity
is so engrossing to human beings that
you can even make a game out of it if
you're,
you know,
a relatively board and stupid adult.
I played that game all the time with my
son by the way.
So I put myself in that category as
well.
Now what the child is doing is they will
accidentally in some ways bumble into
something interesting and then it
recognizes that it's interesting in
because that's a reflex action on his
part.
And then once it recognizes that it's
had that reflex action,
which is kind of,
it's pleasurable,
is as long as it's not too intense,
it's at least interesting.
Then they'll try to imitate what they
just did.
So part of the way you master yourself
is by imitating yourself after you've
asked.
Definitely do dot.
It's something interesting.
It's so smart.
So that's a phd had no shit.
So anyways,
you're playing with the baby and you can
play piece with the baby.
That's a good one.
You're teaching it that you're still
there even though you went away and you
can take all the baby,
which is best done in moderation because
it's not exactly clear that babies enjoy
that.
They just laugh when you do that so that
you like them.
Don't throw them out the window when
they're being annoying and then you can
clean the baby to say tho those are
elements of the care of a baby.
I know that's not very sophisticated,
but you know,
those are some of the basics.
Now the thing that's different about
playing with baby and tickled baby is
that play with baby is an abstraction.
Whereas tickle baby is an action,
right?
And so when you're trying to solve the
mind body problem,
this is how you solve it.
The mind is those abstractions,
the ball,
and he's the actions that those
abstractions ground themselves in.
So it sounded like the mind is attached
to the body.
It's the mind is a sequence of
hierarchically arranged abstractions,
the bottom level of which are not
abstractions,
their actions.
There's a qualitative transformation at
the bottom of the higher,
the highest resolution level of the
hierarchy.
It's action.
Now you can understand piaget very,
very easily if you understand that the
way a baby develops as far as piaget is,
concern is from the bottom up.
So the baby starts with,
it's laying in his crib,
it's a useless thing.
It's laying there.
It can't even focus its eyes,
you know,
it's just barely getting going.
So it's sort of floating in space trying
to figure out what's going on,
you know and it doesn't even know that
it has arms really just sort of detects
texts these things off to the side and
loft it bomb itself in the face with its
arms or scratch itself cause you have to
cut baby's nails really short.
It's otherwise they scratched themselves
because their arms are just,
you know,
wandering around randomly and the baby
sorts.
From a Piagetian perspective,
the baby starts to learn that,
learn what his body is capable of doing
and some of that it just discovers by
accident.
Now there's no doubt some natural
neurological progression that's going
on.
So the baby is learning along the past
that babies can learn.
But still my piaget's perspective,
the baby is doing quite a bit of
exploring to facilitate its neurological
development and more complex animals may
be doing that in the womb,
you know,
trying out their legs and so on,
so,
so that they can run it as soon as they,
you know,
as soon as they get up.
So it's not even obvious that all that
sort of thing is reflexive and automatic
in an animal that is more active when
exported.
So the baby is begins by basically it
sort of develops from the middle
outward.
So what's the baby got when it first
pops into the world?
Well I can't see very well,
although it can focus on about 12
inches,
which conveniently is about the distance
that his head is from its mother's eyes
if it's breastfeeding.
So that's good for social communication.
So the mother can gaze at the baby and
the baby can gaze at the mother and for
some reason they both find that
fascinating.
So babies also very well wired up around
the mouth so it can use its mouth quite
a lot and it can use its Tom,
those,
those come pre wired.
So,
and this is kind of a frightening
observation.
So at the beginning the baby really is
oral because that's all it works.
Like it could smell too,
you know.
But,
but it's,
it's,
it's voluntary capacity for action is
really centered around its mouth.
And you'll notice that babies infant are
toddlers even love to put things in
their mouth.
My son,
when he was a kid,
he used to go in the backyard.
We did feed them.
So that is the reason he goes to the
backyard and pick up acorns and stuff.
His cheeks with them,
just like a chipmunk.
And so,
you know,
then we take them up to the bath and
we'd have to like dig all the acorns out
of his cheeks.
And he did that for oh God.
Way longer than you'd expect any same
child to do it.
So,
but the reason that he would put things
in his mouth and you think about this is
there's nothing that's a better
exploratory Oregon.
Then your tongue,
I mean,
check out one of your teeth.
Bloody thing feels like it's about this
big to your tongue.
As you'll notice if you ever get a two,
three boom,
it's like the Grand Canyon was just
extension inside your mouth.
And then of course your tongue will work
like mad of its own accord to
investigate every tiny little crevice in
that new hole because your brain wants
to know what's your mouth and what
isn't.
So that if there's something in your
mouth that either should or shouldn't be
a,
it can tell it from you and B,
it can tell whether or not it's supposed
to be there.
It turns out to be very important,
right?
Because while there's tooth decay,
that's a problem.
But you know there's also insects and
poison and all sorts of other things
that you shouldn't put in your mouth.
So don't underestimate the degree to
which you can zoom around the world like
a know hoover vacuum cleaner and pick up
our god awful amount of information.
And of course you're also seemed that
way obviously.
And so you know,
you're checking out your mother with
your mouth and your tongue and a very
meaningful way to,
and well,
you're feeding at the breast,
you're establishing the basis of social
relationships.
Now this puts a bit of a warp into the
piaget,
the hypothesis,
because piaget sort of assumed if the
baby built,
he builds himself from the bottom up,
right?
But one of the things you have to
understand is that the baby is always
picking up how to behave and see in a
very,
very social context.
Even when it's so young.
That phd would regard it as primarily
egocentric because what the hell does a
baby knew about you?
You know?
But the mother is teaching the child how
to act right from the time.
It's a little tiny thing.
Like if it's going to breastfeed,
it has to do it in a relatively
civilized manner because if it bites his
mother or her mother,
which are baby can do,
they can really chump you a good one.
If their minds are made up to do that,
it's like unpleasant consequences are
going to ensue.
At minimum the mother is going to start
[inaudible],
you know,
stop feeding the baby and maybe she'll
put the baby down or,
or God only knows.
One time when my son was very young,
I guess he was about 13 months,
he had just learned to walk and he
walked up to my wife who was wearing
shorts and he bit her right here and a
good chunk.
He was just teasing and she reflex
reflex and he like,
he must have flown six feet.
It's like that's how you socialize
children against the sudden bias.
So even the smallest alterations of
their behavior take place within an
intensely social context.
So even at this level,
this society is,
is helping guide and restrict the
development of the child's motor
activities.
Now children tend to develop,
as I said,
they develop gross body movements first.
So they kind of learn to fling their
arms.
So maybe you put a mobile in the crib
for your baby,
look at,
by the way,
most mobiles you'll notice maybe their
fish.
So you're a parent,
you're standing here and this is the
side of the fish and this is the bottom
of the fish and that's what the baby is
looking at.
It's like the baby is looking at lines
because the fish in here for the adults,
it's like that's a stupid mobile.
You get that fish turned over so that
baby can see the fish and then you make
them out of like black and white because
babies are very good at picking up high
contrast and that's a baby mobile rather
than a mother and mobile.
So you got to decide whether the mobile
is for you or for your baby.
So anyways,
you put the mobile above the baby and he
kind of want to put it within limb
length and then the baby will watch this
thing.
Who knows?
Maybe tonight to Devin.
By this,
the,
we know,
it's like,
you know,
and then it'll will sort of flail boat.
Like it does not very well controlled
better.
And maybe it will flail an arm or leg
and now I'm to get lucky and it'll nail
one of those fish.
And now starbucks.
And so usually that it might try that
because that might have just,
if it's a neurotic baby,
it'll cry.
It's like that's too much for today.
But if it's a kind of a outgoing,
exploratory maybe,
then the next thing it's really good to
want to do is to figure out how to make
that fish move again.
And then it'll sit there and practice
flailing its leg.
It's like it's throwing its leg at the
fish and if it gets lucky it will nail
it a good one.
And then that'll make it laugh.
And then,
you know,
the practice doing that over a sequence
of babies are persistent manner.
So when my daughter was little,
she was about 18 months old.
We bought her this little cardboard box
that had little cardboard,
Disney books in it,
you know,
and she didn't care what the Disney
books where,
what she was really interested in is
getting those three books out of the
Disney blocks and then trying to get the
back end.
Cause it turned out that was quite
difficult because they fit tightly.
So this was a great puzzle for her.
Cause you know,
she was still getting the whole
coordination thing going and she'd sip
for like three hours getting those
bother those books in that box.
And that was like a toy for,
for a week until she figured it out.
And then she was on to bigger and better
things.
But that's a big deal,
right?
You can imagine what you're doing.
You're logically,
when you're doing that,
it's like first of all,
you've got to grip that book property
second you go to oriented precisely
third as you add the additional books to
the box,
the shape changes because the book's
flop over,
you know,
cause they'll flop over diagonally.
So the shape changes.
Who's going to figure out how to adjust
that and then the book itself will open
and that will get in the way.
So you're going to keep the book closed
and you know the tolerances that are
like an 18th of an inch.
So,
so you want to master that.
And like some people don't.
I had a client once who had a very low
fluid intelligence,
probably 75 80 you would have known it
by looking at him but he couldn't find
employment.
Surprise,
surprise.
There's,
there's no jobs in our society for
people who are at that end of the
cognitive distribution.
I got to the volunteer job at one point
and his job was to put paper in
envelopes,
had to fold it up in three cause that's
how you fold up a piece of paper and
then you have to put an envelope.
But that actually turns out to be hyper
complex.
I probably trained him for 28 to 30
hours to do that.
And because
when you do it next time or you could do
it now,
you just think about what you're doing
is first of all,
merely by observing the piece of paper,
you'd have to figure out how to make the
first full and it better be damn close
to one third.
Because if it isn't,
when you make the second fold,
you're going to compound your error and
then you're going to find,
to your chagrin than a piece of paper
does not fit in the envelopes because
the envelope is exactly the same size as
the piece of paper.
So if you're out by your estimate,
say a quarter of an inch in your first
full of road by half inch of your second
fold,
it's like it's not going in there.
Or if,
if you don't fold it completely at 90
degrees,
you know,
so the edges line up,
say you're out by a 16th of an inch and
then you do that again.
So now you're out by eight,
it won't fit in sideways.
So then you have to mangle the envelope
to,
to get the paper in there.
And then by the time you've done
mangling the envelope,
not only does it look ugly,
but he will not go through an automatic
sorting machine.
So,
and then added to that was the problem
that on these pieces of paper,
there were often photograph staple
because he was working for a charity.
So then,
but the photographs weren't always
stapled at exactly the same place on the
piece of paper.
So then you'd have to look at the piece
of paper and he'd have to figure out
where the photograph is and then you'd
have to figure out how to fold a piece
of paper so that he didn't bend the
photographs so that it would still fit
in the envelope.
And that just used to,
he just sweat himself to death trying to
solve that problem because there was
time pressure too.
So,
and there's an added level of complexity
on top of that.
And the reason I'm telling you this,
because you'll give it some sense of how
you know,
simple actions are aggregated into
increasingly complex operations.
Some of the envelopes were French and
some of them are English because it was
Canada.
And so you couldn't put a French letter
in an English envelope if the French
ones had to go in a separate pile.
And then there was a huge stack say of
English letters and a huge stack of
English envelopes,
all of which hypothetically had been
stacked so that each one on to the
other,
but now and then one of them would be
out of alignment.
So then you had to figure out whether it
was the letters that were out of the
alignment or the envelopes.
Well that's a,
that's a high complexity working memory
problem that just bring him to a
standstill.
So anyways,
you know,
during typical development you develop
those incredibly fine motor skills,
easy early,
which is part of the reason why it's
kind of Nice to have your baby,
toddler,
infant do something by itself,
you know,
like sit there with a box until it gets
a little bored and then it'll start to
figure out what to do with the box.
And that's part of play.
And that's part of the development of
its in boarding conceptual structure.
So,
okay.
so you basically the chain these things
together.
Now the way that piaget,
he thought,
well what's the motivation for doing
this?
So the motivation is essentially is
that,
well sometimes it can be sort of random.
You accidentally do something
interesting and then try to repeat it.
But as you sort of develop the number of
times that you do something accidentally
that results in something interesting
starts to decline.
Now what part on what happens to you as
you mature is that the opportunities
that are provided for you by your body
as you exercise and then develop it,
start,
continue,
you know,
start to really ramp up and develop so
that you can do a lot more interesting
things with your body by the time you're
two then you can,
when you're nine months old for example,
you can zoom around,
which just opens up a whole universe of
things to pull over and dump over and
pull off tables and you know,
and there's things lying around that you
can write on walls with and you can pull
out cupboards and it's like,
it's,
you know,
paradise for an exploratory date.
Maybe.
So,
but what happens is that as the child
puts himself or herself together
physically and develops additional
skills,
then they can elicit additional
manifestations of novelty from the
world.
So for example,
right?
Well,
here's a good example.
So the child finally manages to get
itself upright,
which is like a colossal,
colossal,
an amazing accomplishment.
You know what I mean?
First of all,
that's hard to do.
Like no,
there are two legged creatures in the
world except for us,
you know,
and we're so good at this.
You can even,
isn't that wonderful?
I learned that when I was two.
So you know,
you can do these amazing things with
your body,
but the child is like trying to put
itself together neurologically and it's
a hell of an operation to get this call
them of bone.
It's like jellyfish on a bone,
you know,
or,
or stack bones and you got to get the
thing to stand up upright.
God ridiculously difficult.
So the child manages that.
There's a lot of pain and anguish
associated with that,
right?
Because those little creatures,
they just fall down and you know,
and they got these little short arms.
So they're not much good at protecting
themselves from impact.
They're just bouncing off the walls like
mad and the floor up and they're trying
to learn to walk.
Then they finally get themselves up
right and tartar along and followed and
so on.
But then you know,
then the world turns into a different
place because all of a sudden now you
can stand up underneath the table.
That's the fun.
That's a fun thing to do for the first
time.
It's like lack.
So now your new body has taught you
something about the world that you did
not know.
So what piaget would say is,
well,
you've got the scheme worked out,
which is the standing up scheme.
And it turns out that at works pretty
well if you're in an empty space.
But if you're in a close space with a
low ceiling,
the whole standing rock thing,
it's just not going to produce,
produce the results intended.
So he had stand up and whack yourself
and that's a sign that it's time to
update your representational structures.
And so you can think of that technically
as the emergence of the normally into
what would have otherwise been a
conceptually protected space.
PSA has this idea of acrylic ration.
So let's say your baby crawls
and let's say it's a Nyquil upgraded
crawler,
which means it's kind of an expert in
babies get pretty expert crawlers by
about,
I'd say 1213 months,
hey can zoom around and they know how
luck I bumped into things and you know
how to crawl around without hurting
themselves.
So when they crawl around only the
things that they want to have happen
half most of the time,
and there are cooperating at that point
because their actions and their
conceptions of the consequence of those
actions match.
They've got no problem.
What they expect or want to have happen
when they crawl is what happens.
That babies APP has mastered a
developmental stage.
So that's the stage idea and that's the
calibrated stage idea.
Corroboration is a brilliant idea and
I'll tell you why in a minute.
But then all of a sudden the baby learns
to stand up.
It's like,
oh,
I did advance.
But it's like a revolutionary advance,
right?
It's equivalent to a revolution in
science,
which is why psg mentioned coon.
It's like,
well,
now I'm a standing creature.
The whole crawling expertise is hardly
worth it at all.
You know,
there's some transfer of knowledge,
but the you new universe that's made
accessible to the baby by it's now
daunting ability to stand forces it to
revolutionize its entire cognitive
structure.
Now I'll give you want to tell you a
very quick story because it's a very
good one.
So this is a good indication of the
function of dream in place.
So when my daughter was three,
she couldn't talk very well.
She,
she learned to speak late and we lived
in Boston and when she learned to speak,
cheat,
developed a Boston accent,
which we were completely flabbergasted
by because we didn't have a Boston
accent and neither did any of our
neighbors.
It turns out there's a speech impediment
that sounds just like a Boston accent.
But anyway,
she was
usually goes away except in Boston.
So anyway,
she,
she was,
she was three and when her brother was
born,
there's always the possibility of
sibling rivalry,
right?
Because,
and for good reason,
it's like,
okay,
time to get rid of that thing.
All it's doing is taking a hold of mum's
attention.
You know,
like that's a hard reality for a child
who's under three to manage because
they're still pretty dependent and it's
like,
well why should they be liking this
horrible,
noisy attention grabbing interloper?
So we tried to,
we tried to teach her right from the
time he came home,
her,
her brother,
that the idea where she was going to
lose something,
which was some parental attention,
especially from her mother,
but she was potentially going to gain
something which was maturity,
independence and the possibility of a
new relationship.
Now we couldn't tell her that.
Some parents will tell their three year
olds that it's like in your three year
old is learning.
But look at you when you talk.
But they're actually hearing,
you know how dogs in cartoons here,
people talk.
It's like one on one on one,
one on a walk.
Why don't want to walk.
That's how children hear you talk when
you're talking to them about something
like independence.
Like what the hell did they know about
that?
That's way up there on the hierarchy.
But we tried to teach her to interact
with the baby in such a way that she
would elicit positive feedback from him
and so that they can be friends.
And then we also taught her that she
should take care of the baby and that
gives her something to do.
So that worked.
We also didn't let them tease each
other.
Not much.
You know,
they're going to tease each other a bit
because it,
siblings often bloody hate each other
when they're,
when they're young.
And sometimes that just destroys the
relationship for their whole life.
It's like you don't want that because
you're stuck with your dad and brother
until he dies,
hopefully,
or until you do.
So.
Anyway,
so my daughter was taking care of this
little guy and you know,
she used to watch them on the stamps and
sort of shepherd him around and she was,
she was pretty good at it.
And then,
um,
one day he started to walk and she kept
talking about her baby and we told her
that,
well,
he wasn't reading a baby anymore and we
didn't realize that this was setting off
a cognitive revolution of the Piagetian
cert because of course she'd Kinda grown
attached to this baby,
just like mothers and my do sometimes
get so attached to their babies that
they really don't want them to stop
being babies.
And so they end up living in their house
till they're 55,
you know,
wanting to destruction of the world.
So you don't want to have that happen.
So,
but it was happening in the microwave
with her.
It's like,
well there's this baby and I spent a lot
of time getting used to it and figuring
out what to do with it.
Now it's not a baby anymore.
What the hell is it?
So she had this amazing dream and it
ties back to the [inaudible] stuff that
I caught you guys about earlier.
So this is the dream.
She dreamed that the baby crawl into a
hole in the backyard.
Now,
the way the whole got there was that a
tree from the park beside us had moved
into our backyard and then hit burned
down and left this hole and then the
whole was full of water.
And so the baby crawl into the water and
it reduced them to a skeleton.
And then there was a bug in the water
and the bug pulled him out.
And when he came out he was a new
creature.
So it was,
it was perfect.
Like she came and told me that,
I don't know,
like two in the morning in her little
three year old voice and they go into
all type down.
It was absolutely spectacular because it
wasn't straight shamonic tree,
like the tree burned down.
And so that's a transformation motif.
And then water is the place of rebirth
and you know,
the kid was dissolved into a skeleton
and the little bug that pulled them out,
it's like a representation of the
underlying process that guides
transformation.
Your own brain was working like mad and
trying to figure out
continuity over change.
That's a tough one,
right?
Because it's almost like a butterfly
urging from a cocoon.
It's a big deal,
baby to toddler.
That's a big difference.
You know,
she's supposed to figure out,
well that's the same thing.
Well no it's not.
So underneath her unconscious mind,
you know,
three year olds are not stupid.
Even though they can't talk,
they've got this brain that's like 3.5
billion years old.
It's not stupid.
So,
so anyways,
no,
why was I telling you that?
Oh well then it's another indication of
how,
so the transformations of cognitive
structure are forced upon a child,
at least in part by the development of
increasing physical ability,
right?
Because as you increase its physical
ability and capacity,
then the world transforms and then your
cognitive processes have to transform to
keep up with them.
And sometimes that's a radical
transformation.
So Piaget's fundamental hypothesis is
that part of the reason that people are
motivated to undergo cognitive
transformations and learning per se is
because as they mature,
they re they automatically come into
contact with anomalous information,
information that they cannot process
from within the confines of the current
world model.
And because they kind of process it,
it interferes with them getting what
they want.
And so they're motivated to keep their
cognitive structures updated.
So in,
sometimes the revolutions occur at a
micro level and that might be like when
you're learning the difference between
this and this,
you know,
it's like it's a major difference but it
doesn't disrupt the whole fabric of your
conceptual universe.
Whereas a divorce,
Mike,
the baby transformed me into a toddler
might.
Puberty does.
It's just like you just find the gun
used to your body.
You're 12 years old,
so you're sort of at the pinnacle of
childhood.
You're like an adult child,
you know what you're doing.
And 11 and 12 year olds are often lovely
creatures because they're pretty mature
and they've got their act together and
then all of a sudden bang sex hormones
kick in.
It's like you are no longer the same
thing and neither is anyone you interact
with.
And so it's like turbulence for three,
four or five 2030 years until you sort
of sort that out,
which she never really do.
And so you can see how
the physiological transformations that
are attended on development,
some biologically predicated and some
and emergent consequence of learning
disrupt the cognitive structures that
people use to orient themselves in the
world.
And that some of those disruptions are
sort of low key equivalent to normal
science now to be assimilation and some
of them much broader.
And that's equivalent to accommodation.
Assimilation means you learn something
new that you can already handle using
the constructs and scheme is that you
have at hand.
You know,
so maybe you have to pick the thing up
like this instead of like this,
but you already know this and you know
that.
So who cares?
It's like a little minor alteration and
sometimes,
well no,
you have to readapt your whole body in
order to handle the next level of
complex problem solving.
Learning to drive is like that.
Learning to ride a bicycle is like that.
And you can see that there's sort of a,
there's not really normal versus
revolutionary transformation.
There's sort of a continuum that Mac
themselves onto that hierarchy I showed
you.
You know?
So if at the very highest levels of
resolution,
it's minor transformations,
send up the higher levels of
abstraction,
you can blow out whole huge chunks of
yourself.
So it's a continuum.
But Piaget and coon sort of
conceptualized it hasn't.
All right.
Let's see.
That's a map of that which you can look
up.
Um,
Oh yes,
this is the,
this,
this is the thing I really want to get
out to this is,
it's so brilliant.
And so psa was concerned about morality
and he's one of the few psychologists I
think,
who like,
he nailed it.
It's this is like the most important
thing piaget discovered and maybe it's
one of the most important things that a
psychologist has ever discovered.
It's like how do you become moral?
Well,
we've already mentioned that when you
acquire a behavior,
you inevitably acquire in a social
context.
So what that means is that right from
the time you're little and learning
things,
the demands of society are encoded in
the behaviors that you're allowed to
manifest.
And so science to some degree,
by the time you behave the way you do
behave,
you're three.
If you've been properly socialized,
you already act out the embodied moral
structure of your entire community.
So you know when you talk about law,
as you say,
there's a body of laws and the body of
law is used to be the cake.
So you have to do with the king set up.
But now the body of laws is an abstract
conceptual representation.
But those representations are actually
semantic representations of allowable
and not allowable behavior.
And so by the time you're three and
you're a law abiding three year old,
which means you're well socialized,
you're already acting in accordance with
the law,
the patterns that characterize your
beating,
the behavioral patterns that
characterize your Ba have already been
molded into the patterns that you
manifest.
And so what that means in some sense is
you're already,
as Nietzsche would say,
an unconscious advocate of your culture
because you're acting it out.
Now here's an example.
Here's an example of how that can be
transformed into actual moral knowledge.
So he has,
he goes to the studies kids playing a
game.
So here's an example.
So there's a bunch of kids and they're
standing around in the playground and
they're all playing helicopter.
Maybe they've just got sticks and
they're always,
you know,
when they're flying in helicopters
around and they're all doing this and
maybe they're diving in each other.
So what's happened is each kid wants to
have a helicopter and each kid wants to
be a good helicopter pilot.
But each kid wants to be a good
helicopter pilot in the way that other
kids appreciate.
Well,
they're being good helicopter pilots.
That's tough phase.
So not only do you have to figure out
how to coordinate your behavior,
you have to figure out how to coordinate
your behavior with other people,
coordinating,
coordinating their behavior in such a
way that the shared activity not only
does not come to a stop,
but precedes an enjoyable way.
Jesus,
that's really tough.
Now if your kid can play well with other
kids,
that's what they've managed.
Okay,
so you've got four kids doing this and
there's rules.
Actually there's not,
there's rituals that the children are
embodying that they've agreed upon.
Well,
they set up the game and they've just
sort of bash the ideas up against each
other and they came up with a solution.
And you can tell that because the game
is continuing and everyone is having
fun.
It's like,
is everyone playing nice?
Yes,
that's an equivalent rated place state.
And it's a moral organization because
all the children are participating
voluntarily towards a shared end.
And as for piaget,
that was the model of a functional
society.
That's so smart.
So now imagine that a kid comes along
and maybe he's a popular kid,
so he has a reasonable chance of getting
into this playgroup.
You'll still be robust like 50% of the
time.
Whereas if he's not blocking her kid,
it's like forget,
they're just not going to let him into
the little helicopters circle.
And there's probably because he's
developmentally delayed or an in some
other way,
he doesn't understand how we asked to
configure his behavior so that he can
enter this complex,
dramatic scene without disrupting it.
Or maybe he's one of those kids who
says,
I don't want to bring helicopter,
we should play something else.
It's like,
no,
unless you're a creative genius.
That's a pretty bad idea.
So what the popular kids do,
if they sort of side loft to the group,
maybe they find a stick cause they watch
what they're doing,
maybe they find a stick and they sort of
started going cause this is sick and
they're sort of looking at to see if
that stick helicopter behavior is
acceptable to the peers.
And maybe,
you know,
one of the friends sort of notices that
they're playing helicopters and they
open up the circle of Maca and gets to
come in and play helicopters.
But he might fail it out even if he's
popular.
Because once in the little play thing is
going,
it's like a plague,
right?
It's got a dramatic structure.
You can't just come in there and you
know,
start playing basketball or something.
So now what Piaget noticed was that when
children were playing your game,
maybe they were playing,
Barbara's not so rough game and you
because you can win and lose it.
Marvelous.
And you might say,
well,
children shouldn't play competitive
games.
But if you say that,
that's a sure sign that you don't know
what the hell you're talking about
because all games are competitive and
cooperative at the same time.
If they share a single goal and it's
really not a game unless there's a goal.
Cause goal games have goals.
And so what the children do is they,
they organize themselves.
So they all decide what constitutes an
acceptable goal.
And the goal with marvel says when some
marbles and lose the marbles without
whining about it,
that's another goal.
And that's an important thing to learn.
So the children say,
well,
here's the foundation of our local moral
universe.
Here's the rules that we're going to
abide.
By and large,
those are ritualistic.
They might've learned them from other
kids.
So they play marbles.
You extract out a kid and you say,
what are the rules for marbles?
And if it gets like seven,
they don't know.
They can't tell you.
But if you put them in with a bunch of
other seven year olds,
they can play marbles perfectly well.
So what that means is the morality is
coated in their behavior or in the
behavior of the group,
like a bunch of feeds,
you know,
cause there's knowledge in a hive of
bees or making it a school of fish.
So it's embedded in the child's behavior
and in their patterns of action across
time.
And then if you pull them out,
they can only give like a partial of the
counter,
but they're not conscious of the
morality.
It's like it pulled a war fighter of a
wolf pack and say,
well you know what's up with the wolf
pack and the wall,
you know,
bites you because that's just,
that's how it answers questions.
It's not going to tell you about the
rules.
It's only later in development that the
children become conscious of the rules
and then they become very irritated that
people break them and they don't much
later do.
They start to understand that the rules
can be adjusted by mutual agreement and
that is associated with the Phn and
development of higher order of morality.
It's brilliant.
You learn your actions,
your actions are conditioned by other
people.
The actions are integrated into a
voluntary game.
Then the actions are integrated into a
series of voluntary games.
That social interaction,
then you learn the descriptions.
Then you learn how to manipulate the
descriptions.
Brilliant.
Moving up the hierarchy,
snatch a Piagetian theory.
In a nutshell constructed,
this is a nutshell.
See you on Thursday.